(intense music)
- Yawning.
Some say it's contagious,
some people say it's not.
Today, we find out.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you as well.
- Nice to meet you.
- Burger time.
- Oh
- They're like my favorite food.
(yawning)
- [Voiceover] Oh let's go get the food.
- Girl, where they at?
- I wonder if she's getting
them from multiple places
or if it's all from one place.
- I haven't done stand-up
enough to be really good at it.
(bell rings)
(Yawns loudly)
- You need some coffee or some Red Bull.
(buzzing)
- Gotta reserve that energy.
(bell rings)
- Thank you.
- So
(bell rings)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
(yawning)
- Where are they?
- [Voiceover] Okay, there are no burgers.
- Guys.
- Seriously?
- No!
God damn it.
- [Voiceover] That's the video?
Did you yawn?
- You did.
- Oh I did?
- And I didn't yawn,
so it's not contagious,
thanks a--holes.
Guys.
You're such a dick, I was like oh,
it's lunch time, I'm gonna eat a burger,
and now I yawned.
(upbeat music)